c'était une marche pour ne jamais
oublier chahine à cette adolescente de
15 ans poignardé
brûlée vive par son petit ami est
retrouvée morte dans un cabanon et des
jardins familiaux de creil où nous nous
trouvons actuellement c'était en octobre
2019 et son calvaire à cette adolescente
il commence deux ans plus tôt
lorsqu'elle est victime d'un viol
collectif les images de ce viol ont
quasiment tout de suite était partagé
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est donc une
affaire qui dépasse l'entendement l
inimaginable et qui surpasse tout
scénario de film d'horreur l'objectif
était donc de rappeler de se souvenir du
du sourire de chanas et de se rappeler
également de l'horreur des circonstances
de sa mort plusieurs dizaines de
personnes ont fait le déplacement et ont
déposé des fleurs sur le lieu de la
découverte de la petite china qui se
trouve juste derrière moi c'était sous
ce cabanon qui a été retrouvé son corps
et l émotion était évidemment au rendez
vous écoutez ma fille en 2018 va pas
quand elle sarah fille des trente ans et
va finir tout le temps j'ai eu ma fille
bientôt ça va finir les enquêtés à le
tribunal ils ont tout ça devient déjà à
finir un ma fille allait elle est plus
d'armes à 2017 2019 je m'aime pas été
jugé encore mais c'est quoi cette
justice
1 aujourd'hui c'est vrai bord pourtant
je connais mal de temps je dois des mots
colère 1 tout en jeu j'ai confère à la
justice je vous remercie aussi tout le
monde qui présents aujourd'hui qu'il ne
soutient aussi dans certaine façon c'est
vrai que au début on est restés
silencieux c'est cette affaire parce que
c'était déjà pas facile pour nous d'y
croire même c'était très très très très
difficile après les choses se sont
enchaînées on a pu trouver quelqu'un au
jour d'aujourd'hui il est je sais que
lui il a le droit ou voilà on y est
c'est dit innocent mais pour nous pour
moi ma famille nous on sait très bien
que c'est lui parce que il y a des
preuves très émue la famille souhaite
que justice soit faite pour les deux
affaires celle des viols de 2017 et
celle du meurtre de shana en 2019
j'espère pouvoir alerter dans mon
discours que sahin a pas qu'à nous
opposons tout notre espoir sur la
justice aujourd'hui on n'a que ça on
attend seulement que la justice façon
son travail deux ans après au quotidien
c'est une famille détruite
c'est vraiment difficile pour nous
j'avais bien que l'injustice france et
jora bon bon nous ont fait confiance à
la justice les enquêteurs ont fait
confiance nous ont fait un justice mais
j'avais bien qu'il ait une peine
exemplaire le suspect présumé de la mort
de shana est actuellement incarcéré il
devrait prochainement être jugé devant
la cour d'assises dès mineurs de l'oise